despite having been a graphics
programmer since the early 2000s the
first time I stepped into Horizon
forbidden West I was taken a back by the
sheer scale of the world how do games
like this or Assassin's Creed or
Spider-Man which also boast enormous
detailed Worlds how do they draw all of
this without compromising on performance
it's really interesting because the
techniques used have been built on and
refined for decades at this point so the
first method is relatively simple let's
start with the world and populate it
with some stuff it doesn't really matter
what that stuff is but we'll keep it
relatively simple now let's take a look
from above so let's pretend that we're
taking an eagle eyes view of what the
player is seeing so that's the player
down there and we can visualize what
they see with this green box this is
called The View frustum and it's what
they can see from their perspective and
a view frustum is basically like a box
it's defined by six sides you you have
the left and right which of course
correspond to the left and right parts
of your screen you have the top and
bottom which correspond to the top and
bottom of your screen and finally you
have the near and far the near being how
close you can be to things before they
cut off and the far being how far you
can see those six planes Define
everything that's visible to them this
is called the viewing frustum on top of
that each object in the scene can be
thought of as having a simple volume
around them spes are popular because
doing math with spheres is really simple
things like distance calculations those
sort of things those are a breeze you
can get a much tighter fit with a box
though the downside of course being that
the math tends to be a tiny bit more
complex but not overly so making them a
nice trade-off on efficiency now that we
have this idea of a viewing volume and
each object having a simple bounding
volume then you're simply going to do an
intersection test for every single
object in the scene you test whether
they bounding volume intersects with the
view frustum and everything that's
completely outside that's discarded
because that's not visible and
everything that's inside or bordering
that's drawn remember that this test
needs to be conservative meaning that if
you draw a little too much that's okay
because that's better than drawing too
little if we do that here's our scene
everything that's being discarded is
being colored red while everything
that's being kept is being colored green
and as an example if our world happens
to contain hundreds of objects well with
this simple pass we've whittel down that
number considerably with just this
simple technique but froom culling as
awesome as it is isn't usually enough as
the recently released City skylines 2
found out ignoring all the other
problems with the game this report shows
that they relied solely on frust culling
which is a really big mistake it's the
first step not the only step you need to
go further and this is where occlusion
culling comes in let's take this simple
example of a camera and some object
sitting in the world now we can easily
discard what's blatantly visible or not
with our view frustum check so
everything outside of the viewing
frustum we've already discarded those
being left with just the things inside
the view frust now imagine a big object
here near the camera let's say that it's
a wall or a building or anything big and
solid you can't see past this thing so
we can draw lines from the camera to the
edges of this object and extend them
Beyond forming a volume an area where
realistically nothing inside of it is
visible to you so that's occlusion but
how do we calculate occlusion and most
importantly how do games manage to do it
so fast because this needs to be done
near
instantly let's start with a really
simple idea that occlusion culling isn't
all that different from Custom culling
at least in this simple case here
in Frost them culling we're getting rid
of what's outside of this area defined
by our view or our camera taking a super
simple approach to occlusion culling
it's almost like a reverse of that
instead of getting rid of everything
that's outside of this area we want to
get rid of everything that's inside of
it inside outside outside inside that in
itself isn't all that complex and
perhaps surprisingly some big games in
the past have been shipped with this
extremely simple but effective approach
basically all that it entails is that
somebody goes into Maya or whatever the
3D editing software is and they manually
author occlusion volumes so let's say
that you have your object in the world
you've got a big fat tree or rock or
whatever doesn't really matter that much
then an artist would secretly place a
box or several boxes inside and these
boxes aren't visible to players they're
only used by the rendering system
ideally you'd place a box that fits
pretty snug inside without spilling out
and you do this for every object in the
world that fits some sort of criteria
like it's big enough to be important
that sort of thing so how is it that you
actually perform occlusion coloring with
one of these boxes in a bunch of ways
it's not particularly complex let's draw
a border and this will be our screen and
now let's show The Box on the screen so
we basically need to project the box to
screen space which might sound fancy but
it just means draw it on the screen see
this silhouette here that's defined by
at least four sides and up to six sides
which you can create planes out of
forming a view frust them same as we
dealt with for the camera except in
Reverse so now you've got your data your
set of all the occluders in the scene
and the first thing that you're probably
going to do is a basic fom coling pass
on them to make sure they're even
relevant this is where things get a
little custom for each approach but
basically you're going to pick a bunch
of them how you pick them is kind of up
to you optimization is a game of
tradeoffs you need to decide how much
time to burn in order to save time yeah
so pick too many and you may just spend
way too much time going through them
pick too few and you may not call enough
to make it worth it in practice you may
just do something super simple like pick
the end closest ones and hope for the
best which according to their
presentation from sigraph is what the
developers of Just Cause 2 did the
developers at Avalanche Studios outlined
a simple and easy approach with a simd
optimized box culling system which they
called bfbc or brute force box culling
and that was it no fancy structures
nothing the very first game I worked on
Prototype did something really similar
if I'm remembering right it's been so
long since I looked at that code if you
catch yourself wondering in wouldn't
some sort of tree structure be faster
watch my video memory cache locality and
why arrays are fast theoretically the
tree should win but a Brute Force simd
optimized one may absolutely destroy it
on Modern Hardware so once you've got
something like that in place we can
place a simple uder in the scene and Bam
suddenly a lot of objects that are
behind it aren't getting colored green
anymore they're yellow which in this
case means they're being occluded
it's not perfect and some things can
slip through the cracks we can trivially
set up a situation that doesn't work the
way we might expected to like here we
have two occluders side by side and one
object behind them but in the middle
since neither of these occluders fully
udes the object behind them individually
and we don't create some sort of Union
of occluders because that's complicated
that object gets flagged as drawn so
that's it that's how modern games do
occlusion coling well you can use this
approach if you need a decent but not
absolutely state-of-the-art system what
it does do though is it served as a
great jumping off point to understand
some of the other techniques when you
draw a scene you don't only generate the
color that's on the screen you also
generate what's called a depth buffer
and this is really useful for the GPU
what this does is keeps track of the
depth of every pixel on the screen and
this allows us and the GPU to do a
variety of things for the GPU it allows
us to do things like render things in
the right order but also discard things
that aren't visible if we didn't have a
depth buffer the scene would be a mess
parts of objects would draw through
others and then you'd have to resort to
sorting the individual triangles of the
entire scene in order to have any hope
at all of drawing things somewhat okay
with a depth buffer now the GPU can
simply compare the depth of what you're
rendering against what's already there
there and if it's closer it gets drawn
and if not it doesn't for us it's pretty
interesting too because we have a
texture that basically has the depth of
the scene available we can create
effects like this fire that doesn't clip
into the scene or even sheet and make
really cheap Reflections like we're
seeing with this water the interesting
part in the context of occlusion culling
is how it allows us to discard entire
objects that aren't visible if we
already had a depth buffer John Let's
ignore the problem of how do we generate
one and let's say that I can somehow
Magic One into existence at the
beginning of the frame how useful would
it be the answer is of course super
useful if we somehow had that we'd be
able to read from it and do comparisons
so if I wanted to check if I can draw an
object we could take its bounding volume
and we could take the screen space
bounds of that map those to our depth
buffer and do a comparison of the
object's depth in the scene with the
values in the depth buffer if it's
behind the values in the depth buffer
poof we eliminate the entire object with
the GPU ever having done any work at all
in fact we could go a step further say I
take that depth buffer and progressively
down sample it to form a myip chain or
hierarchy of these occlusion Maps well
then when we project the screen space
bounds of our object we can simply
choose the appropriate MIP level so that
we only have to read four Tex
and Bam an even faster and easier
comparison these are called hierarchical
Zed buffers or they're often referred to
as H zbs which we'll be doing from this
point forward so remember hzb refers to
this hierarchy of Zed buffers this sort
of chain of progressively downsampled
occlusion Maps but we have a chicken and
egg situation here all this depends on
having a depth buffer but that's created
as part of rendering the scene but we
need this to to decide what to render to
save us work which is a bit of a problem
isn't it early gpus were pretty
restricted and what they allowed you to
do and not do and one thing that wasn't
easy was to read the depth buffer back
so that we could play with the data
ourselves one way around that is to not
bother with the GPU at all and implement
the software rasterizer I mean Quake
came out in 1996 and required a Pentium
75 so there's no reason that with vastly
more powerful Hardware you shouldn't be
able to spit out a few polygons on
screen really really quickly and you can
do all sorts of optimizations here
remember the occlusion coling doesn't
have to be perfect it has to be good
enough and really fast so one thing that
you can do is instead of drawing a full
resolution buffer you can render to half
resolution or you can go even further
and go quarter resolution I mean
whatever works right and you can hand
build your uder still well I mean have
artist make them and your software Ware
rasterizer is basically only responsible
for drawing out something that would
look low poly even in the PS1 era the
approach itself isn't that complex the
initial steps of this are really similar
to what we had before we do frustum
calling and such on the scene and we
also get the list of includers the new
part is here we have our new hzb and
that can be whatever resolution works
good enough and fast then you draw all
of your occluders into that and once
that's done you'll go ahead head and
down sample that to form the hierarchy
then you use that filled in hierarchy to
manually test objects to see if they're
visible or not and that's it
conceptually it's not super complex so
here we can see the H thatb in action
with rendered objects in the top right
corner we've got on display the top
level mid map basically the depth that
was being drawn out we've also got a few
more levels of the H that' be underneath
at various MIP levels one of the really
interesting things to take note of is is
that look at how as you go towards the
lowest resolution the bright or far away
pixels are kind of taking over
everything that's because we do this
conservatively as we down sample we
always pick the furthest away value now
of course doing it this way isn't
perfect but it gives you a bunch of
advantages over the previous box only
method recall the example we looked at
earlier of having an object sitting
behind two occluders which failed
miserably because of the approach being
used well you using this new approach of
generating your occlusion map CPU side
the union of occluders is not only
possible but a natural consequence of
the approach as you can see here we've
got two big occluders side by side and
they're uding the object behind it in
fact if we change this up and now we can
have a whole bunch of thin objects lined
up side by side and the overall net
effect of them is the same as having one
giant wall look at the object behind it
now stays yellow the system is now
reporting it as uded or even better yet
we can see that using nonbox shapes like
here I've got a disc and the technique
doesn't care at all the shape of your
objects your occluders doesn't matter in
the slightest here we're using the
infamous Stanford bunny but as an uder
the shape of your occluders no longer
matters which is amazing because it
grants this huge amount of flexibility
that was lacking before an example of a
game that launched with this was K Zone
3 in their sigraph 2011 talk Gorilla
Games talks about using spus on the PS3
now if you've never done any PS3
development the PS3 shipped with what
was called the cell Broadband engine
under the hood you had a power PC main
CPU and Nvidia GPU and developers had
access to I believe six of the spus or
synergistic processing units which were
these stupidly powerful but difficulty
to use Vector processors anyway
programming for them was a pain but if
you had the right workload in a lot of
patients once you got them working boy
could they do a lot so Killzone 3
generated their occlusion map using a
simplified version of the scene a lower
resolution depth buffer and some highly
optimized spu side rendering Battlefield
3 gave a really similar talk at GDC 2011
entitled coloring the battlefield where
they went into detail in a really
similar approach for their famous
frostbite engine used in so many EA
games but let's be real gpus are just
way better at drawing than the CPU is
because the raw horsepower they have is
absolutely unmatched and that Gap is
only growing every year not getting
smaller ideally then what you want is
that you want to get the GPU to Simply
tell us what we want to know which is
exactly what started happening we
started getting support for things like
Hardware occlusion queries a mechanism
for just asking the GPU hey how much did
you draw the idea is pretty simple you
could draw part of your scene like maybe
just the major occluders then once
you've done that you want to figure out
all the small things whether they're
visible or not so you take the bounding
volumes of those objects and issue
queries to the GPU asking if they're
visible or not if they're not visible
you can ignore them if they are you can
choose to render them for real later
article like Hardware occlusion queries
made useful appeared in places like the
GPU gem series that went into detail on
how you could use these queries to build
very general purpose occlusion calling
systems the team on Splinter Cell
conviction went this route at first
ditching their pre-computed visibility
system in favor of a new one built
around this newly exposed functionality
the problem was that issuing a lot of
these queries incurred CPU overhead and
you don't get the answer immediately
both of these pose significant problems
if you want to cut down on queries your
first idea is probably some sort of
hierarchy of bounding volumes so you'd
have some sort of hierarchy of bounding
volumes where each node represents the
bounding volume of all the children so
this root node for example is the
bounding volume of everything so given a
node in the tree you do a query using
that node's combined bounding volume
saving you the CPU overhead of having to
run a query on each object je if that
query fails the entire subtree is
invisible and you can safely move on but
that of course runs head first into the
other issue which is you don't get the
answer immediately so you could just
stall and wait for the answer which is
super easy and just an awful idea you
don't want the GPU or the CPU just
sitting there idle so then you come up
with various attempts to mitigate that
problem like Nvidia was proposing here
but ultimately it's a whole can of worms
and difficult to get working well which
is why the Splinter Cell team just
wholly abandoned all the work they did
and went in another Direction late in
the project they pivoted away from their
query based system to something that's
getting a lot closer to what's in use
today they take their set of includers
and remember that these can be
simplified versions of existing geometry
and render them out to a depth buffer
and now they have a depth buffer they
use that to build a depth hierarchy
similar to what we showed before so each
level is half the resolution of the last
and you take the maximum depth of the
four texels from the higher resolution
map that turn into one in the lower
resolution then they take everything
they want to test and they draw that as
a series of points so each point knows
the screen space extents of the object
they want to test and the depth it's
testing and it's responsible for
outputting a pixel with visible or not
visible then that final single render
Target is read back from the GPU to the
CPU
and now they can see the results of
their queries and the awesome thing
about this approach was that most of it
happened on the GPU there's only this
single stall at the end reading back but
in reality renderers have a crapload of
work to do on the CPU as well so if you
can frontload this occlusion work early
in your frame meaning you do it as early
in your frame update as you can then
shove in whatever other bookkeeping work
you can find let the GPU do its thing
and then do your single readback
afterwards then it's not the end of the
world one set of problems that we'd like
to get away from though is this manual
work step of authoring occlusion
geometry and having to select excluders
to use that's time being spent that
could be spent on making more content
polish that sort of thing one
observation that you can make about any
given scene is that from one frame to
the next very little changes in reality
to generate the current frame we mostly
take the last frame and mutate it a tiny
bit objects might be moving around but
at 60 FPS for example that translates
into barely anything same with the
camera that will have moved but only
ever so slightly what if we could
exploit this somehow one attempt to
exploit this temporal coherence was
described by the developers from
Assassin's Creed their approach seemed
to be to take a bunch of the nearby
stuff and render it into a depth buffer
then they take last frames depth buffer
reproject that to the current frame and
combine those together wait what's
reprojection the idea isn't overly
complex if you know roughly where things
were last frame where the camera was and
which direction things were moving then
you can reproject or in other words
guess where they should be this Frame
that's all anyway so they describe using
this approach of combining the old and
new creating the hzb from that and then
doing their occlusion queries so that's
a really NE NE approach but
unfortunately quite difficult to manage
properly as you might have guessed
reprojecting the depth is difficult to
do well with a lot of special casing in
the engine and implementation in order
to accommodate this approach the basic
assumption that stuff doesn't change too
much from frame to frame that's still
good but the technique wasn't quite
right so that leads us to more or less
what's being used today in engines like
unreal the basic idea is that all the
stuff that passed the visibility test
last frame they're very likely visible
this Frame so take those probably
visible objects and use them as
occluders so we draw all of those and
then we take the depth or Zed buffer and
we build the hzb so if you're wondering
this doesn't seem totally right because
let's say that an object was offscreen
before and now it's suddenly on screen
they should be occluding things but
that's not happening right and that's
okay this approach is conservative you
might overdraw a bit like I said before
that's better than missing things
secondly because it was offs screen and
we only drew things that were on screen
we didn't even draw this new object well
that's a problem so we need to move into
the second phase of this algorithm this
approach is known as two pass occlusion
culling because well it has two passes
it's right there in the name it's not a
mystery in this second pass we're going
to go over everything that wasn't drawn
the first time and we're going to retest
it against the hzb that we built in step
one so that big shiny new object that
moved into the middle of the screen that
will obviously pass the test and get
drawn and because nowadays we have
compute shaders we have the ability to
generate the arguments for draw calls
themselves this entire pipeline all of
these steps takes place on the GPU which
is awesome what does the future bring
I'm not sure there's really exciting
work being presented where individual
objects are now being broken apart and
occlusion cult which is a logical next
step and then you have technology like
nanite from Unreal Engine which is
something of an automatic level of
detail system very cool stuff be under
no illusions that this is a complete
picture of how visibility is done but it
should give you a pretty decent overview
of what's used today and how we got
there we haven't touched on things like
pre Ed visibility or other aspects of
just making the scene cheaper in general
to render there's so much work that goes
into modern rendering and we've just
started scratching the surface cheers